I hate to say see I told you so but I
told you so it's all unfolding exactly
as I said it would on December 6 when
Senate Democrats were giving out Frank
and the bums rushed based on allegations
of impropriety he almost entirely denied
what did I say now before you join the
march up the castle to the castle
Frankenstein to capture the monster I
have a word of caution they've come down
with a sudden case of feverish morality
but what it really is is nothing more
than a political calculation by the Dems
they have two paths to destroy the
president the first is the molar
investigation the second way they're
gonna try to destroy the Trump
presidency is the war on women yeah that
old saw they have now determined that
it's worth sacrificing Franken just like
they did John Conyers throw them
overboard to save the political Titanic
that is their party now one what does
this do
it sets the precedent for the Democrats
to try to drive Roy Moore from office
should he win the Alabama Senate race
and - this is the next step in the quest
to impeach President Trump and let me
tell you bingo like clockwork it was a
coordinated rearing of the grievances
that began just yesterday complaints by
the same Trump accusers that voters had
already heard from before they elected
our 45th president then with impeccable
timing a quartet of Democratic senators
called on the President to resign never
mind that the president has long denied
the charges 130 years old and that there
was nothing new in any of them and in
the dangerous climate we have today that
the Liberals have created allegations
are enough to strip anyone especially
any man of his career senator Kirsten
Gillibrand is the de facto
leader now of the get Trump crusade do
you remember her voicing such plaintive
concern for Bill Clinton's accusers when
he was appearing at her fundraisers
neither do i and more troubling women
who were part of the Trump
administration seemed to be kind of
hedging their bets on Sunday UN
Ambassador nikki Haley had the perfect
opportunity to stand up for the
president really strongly and call out
this politically motivated hysteria
instead she kind of took a pass women
who accused anyone should be heard they
should be heard and they should be dealt
with and I think we heard from them
prior to the election and I think any
woman who has felt violated or felt
mistreated in any way they have every
right to speak up and women who see
themselves as presidential material
need to be heard most of all today NBC's
megyn kelly and what seems to be a new
daily feature showcased another of the
old Trump accusers I demand that he's
subjected to an investigation by the
Ethics Committee I think it's important
that we hold this man to the highest of
standards and if 16 women have come
forward then why hasn't anything been
done where is our investigation it's
curious don't you think how this accuser
issued a call for an investigation just
as 59 House Democrats released a letter
demanding a congressional investigation
into these allegations against the
president I'm sure it's all it's a total
coincidence well here's the reality
congressional Democrats know that time
is not on their side while Roy Moore was
still in the headlines and the me - itis
was still all the rage the liberals had
to move they had to make their move now
you got the booming economy you got
consumer confidence rising you got these
trade deals being renegotiated you have
Trump judges getting confirmed things
are looking up for the president so the
Democrats needed a new storyline and
this is it but my friends do not be
fooled for the party
Ted Kennedy in Bill Clinton this sexual
misconduct crusade has never been about
protecting women it's about taking back
power by any means necessary so now that
Muller's impeachment report is at least
somewhat tainted and the president is
scoring some big wins
Dems needed Chum in the water this is it
so I say let them eat their own if they
wish but they cannot be allowed to kill
off their political adversaries with
unproven allegations and female
politicians and activists should also be
really careful where they take this
because someday maybe men might decide
to turn the tables on them and start
launching their own maybe it's called
hashtag men to movement with wild
decades-old complaints against women in
positions of power you don't think it
could happen just watch then who's going
to be left to call for some modicum of
due process or fairness before lives are
destroyed and that's the angle